So now that you've learned about pacing
your game and making it challenging.
But not too challenging by
adding goals and obstacles.
What else can we do to keep
our players interested?
>> I know I'm getting a lot better
playing our bouncing game by myself but
I wish there was some way I could
know exactly how good I am.
>> Yeah.
It would be great to see how we rank
against other players.
Let's play against each other and
add some competition.
>> All right, when players compete and
have a chance to win or set a record,
they have even more motivation to
keep coming back to your game.
Let's see some different ways that
game apps create competition.
>> One simple way to create some
friendly competition in your app
is to add a leader board which lists
the players with the highest scores or
achievements.
Like in the game Temple Run,
it let's players share their rank with
one another and let's you keep track
of the highest scores over the current
day, the week, and over all time.
Another good way to include
competition is with personal ratings
like the star rating in Angry Birds,
which is an example of
a personal player achievement.
It gives players a number of stars,
one out of three,
based on how well they beat the level.
This gives them an idea of how
skilled they are at the game.
And if they think they can do better,
they'll play the game for a longer time.
And the more time players
spend in your game,
the more money it will
eventually be able to make.
Another way to get players to
keep coming back to your game
is to offer them special timed awards.
Really cool items or mystery stages
during a specific time window.
This is also a great strategy for
getting players who may have
left your game to come back.
By offering a special stage or award you
keep your game exciting and interesting.
For example, puzzle and
dragons have urgent dungeons that can
only be played on a specific day or
within a limited timeframe,
like this dungeon can only
be played on a Thursday.
Other games have daily or
weekly challenges.
And these special timed events, combined
with leaderboards and achievements,
create exciting competition between
members of the gaming community.
And are all great ways to
keep players involved.